E.
Jean Carroll
was awarded
$5 million from him yesterday,
a jury of his peers,
and he basically provided
almost no defense. He didn't show up.
His deposition is taped.
Deposition was a travesty in which,
as Caitlin noted,
he doubled down on his Access
Hollywood claim about what
you get away with.
Unfortunately, or fortunately,
as he said, if you're a star,
she he he he
he went after her again tonight.
Yeah, he just won.
You mean, he
she she just won $3 million
for defamation.
Yesterday, you called her a whack job.
I don't know if we have
some of that sound.
Let's let's run it
back.
I want to ask you
about a significant verdict
that was reached yesterday.
I know
this is something
you want to weigh in on as well.
A Manhattan
jury found that
you sexually abused the writer
Jean Carroll and defamed her.
You've denied this.
But what do you say to voters who say it
disqualifies you from being president?
Well, there aren't too many of them
because my poll numbers just came out.
They went up
Okay.
I think I think
I'm I'm
the only person in history
who had a charge like that.
And usually you leave office,
you say, I'm sorry,
but I'm going to back home.
I'm back home to my family
and I'm going to be rich.
My poll numbers went up
and they went up with the other
fake charge, too,
because what's happening
is they're doing this for election
interfere it's this woman.
I don't know her. I never met her.
I have no idea who she is.
I swear on my children,
which I'd never do.
I have no idea who this one.
This is a fake story, made up story.
We had a horrible
Clinton appointed judge. He was horrible.
He allowed her to put everything in.
He allowed us to put nothing in. Mr..
This is if you're rating
your version of events here right now
to the audience.
You referenced the trial.
You did not go to the trial
and actually testify.
Do you wish that you had testified
it wouldn't have made a difference?
This is a rigged deal.
This was a my lawyer said, sir,
you don't have to do it.
I actually said, I think I should.
It would be respectful.
They said, sir, don't do it.
This is a fake story
and you don't want to give it
credibility.
One thing you go
one thing you did do in this
and I swear and I've
never done that
and I swear to you,
I have no idea who to help.
She's a professional.
She's a whack job now.
His lawyer,
Joe Tacopina, is saying that he is going
they're going to appeal,
even though I don't know
what kind of grounds for appeal.
They really have given the fact
that they didn't
really mount much of a defense.
And there is such a record he have
he has of
of women
accusing him of sexual
assault and harassment.
How does his going on CNN
and calling the woman
who was just awarded $5 million
after a jury found him liable for sexual
abuse and defamation,
calling her a whack job?
Does that play into his attempt
to get an appeal
Before I answer your question,
let me just be very clear.
What we saw tonight was outrageous.
Absolutely.
I'm a very objective person.
The idea that you would have
somebody who is vying
to be the head of the executive branch
say that the jury pool
is the United States of America
are not fair,
that presumptively
we must doubt them
because of how they may vote in elections
that you would allude to,
what kind of a woman
that was, his phrase,
would engage in somewhat
some odd behavior.
The idea of retrying to litigate
in the court of public opinion,
what has already been decided
in a court of law.
It's a phrase called race adjudicator,
which is different than double jeopardy.
We are familiar with the idea
you cannot try somebody twice
for the same crime.
That's in the criminal context.
But courts will look at and say,
hold on,
is there a common
nucleus of facts here
that suggests that we've already dealt
with this issue?
Your comment based on this circumstance,
what you've said,
it really is up
to a judge
to figure out
whether you can bring charges
or bring a lawsuit again
based on that very notion.
It's kind of novel territory
in the sense
that the context
of what he's saying tonight.
But the idea that he is
making that statement,
going beyond that today,
to take credit for the Dobbs
decision, did we all catch that?
Yeah, we're going to get to that.
I just have to get this in
because it was a Supreme Court
of the United States
who are nine Supreme Court members.
We know that they are
inherently appointed
in a political fashion.
But for this president,
to say
that he usurped
essentially the role of the Supreme Court
doesn't bode
well for the credibility of our courts
in this world.
And let me just say this.
I'm sorry to cut you off,
because as the lawyer watching this, I
have to say
I would be salivating
if I were the attorneys for E.J.
and Carol,
if I were the prosecutor,
if I were Jack Smith,
if I were in Georgia,
because every single statement
will line up in a column against
here are the potential claims.